6 31 let's say good morning to nate and
check the roads
we do have two crashes that you
definitely need to be aware of one is on
the south 95 515 before flamingo the
other is one of our least favorite spots
to have a crash like there is a favorite
place to have a crash stop on the 15 at
sahara we'll get to that wanted to start
here over on the 95 515 before you come
up on flamingo
normally at this time of day the
slowdowns are the northbound side
heading into the downtown area with the
ongoing big squeeze but when you have a
crash taking up the three left lanes
you're backed up to the charleston curve
so plan on delays they're trying to get
everybody over to the right meantime
emergency equipment also trying to get
the cars out of the roadway but in the
meantime you have a big delay there all
right let's go over to the south 15 now
this is a around sahara it is a blocking
the hov lane they're also trying to get
those cars out of the roadway the travel
lanes are open but it doesn't take much
to slow folks down south on the i-15
after sahara heather
nate thank you 6 32